A lot of teachers have to add up all their students scores to calculate final
grades. When I was in middle school a lot of my teachers had a paper grade
book, but by putting scores into a computer, teachers might save themselves
some work. We're going to build a HomeworkScores class that will read all of
the scores for one student and give useful summaries of their work. Eventually
it will be able to calculate the total and average scores, and drop the lowest.
But first it needs to read the scores for one student. I started the class for
you. It'll save the scores in an array of doubles, which will be partially
filled. We'll allow the teacher to enter whatever number of scores they feel
like. Let's not worry about re-sizing for right now, we'll just make the array
very big to start with. Before I ask you to implement the readScores method I
want to show you one more thing that's going to help.